mark ruffalo the liberal actor
is making this argument explicitly he's
saying the high gas prices that's a good
thing he's going even further he's
saying the war in ukraine
is a gift to joe biden because that'll
spike the price of gas and that will
give biden an opportunity to move to a
green agenda
this is a moment for president biden to
take
this
um
our momentum
people's fear
they're disgusted with the war they're
discussed with energy prices and and and
use that to solidify a message to the
american people that now is the time to
transition this is where the jobs are
that's where national security is and we
are going to keep pushing him to do it
and this is a this is a gift to the
president as we see it and we see him uh
accepting it in such terms
this is a gift now did mark ruffalo
consciously mean to say
that it's a it's a good thing that
ukrainians are dying and russian
soldiers i guess too but did he did he
mean to say it's a good thing that
thousands and thousands of people are
dying because now we can fight the sun
monster
no i don't think consciously he meant to
say that but that's what he said
that's what that means this war in
ukraine it's a gift
it's a gift and biden can really make
the most of it that's what he's saying
what he's saying
is something that
liberals
have
said and believed for a very long time
which is that
people are the problem
which is that
nature whatever we mean by nature is
much more important than people the
traditional view of our relationship to
the created world is that we are
stewards of it that the world is for us
for our delight and we have to be
responsible stewards of that and what
the left has done is flipped that
entirely according to the left we are
not the highest of creation such that we
the birds of the air and the fowl and
the fish of the sea that's that's all
for us
no
they flipped it such that human beings
are parasites on the earth we're
destroying nature
the the
animals and the trees they're not for us
we need to serve them
we're a plague we've got to thin out our
numbers we've got to stop doing stuff
and you know if if some people get
killed so that gas goes up and increases
more suffering for people who can't heat
their homes and who can't fill their gas
tanks well hey that actually that's
probably a pretty good thing because
that'll force the people to move to
solar energy or windmills or whatever
that's what they really believe and it's
not because of any scientific argument
or anything like that it's just because
they don't like people they care a lot
about humanity in the abstract but they
don't care about actual people
it comes down to as simple
an idea as that conservatives pro-human
pro-people on lots of issues on abortion
on environment environmentalism on
everything on the family and the left
anti-people did you like that clip i'm
glad you did you got to ring the bell
and subscribe that way you'll get
notifications for all the clips and all
the special interviews and all the
special breakouts and all the episodes
and the whole
michael knowles show
universe
you got to subscribe also go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
get your audio podcast type in the
michael knowles show if you would be so
kind leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]